i'm broken
i got a really sad message on youtube uh
for one of my viewers
love you guys and i wanted to share with
you and also tell you a story
bengi wrote in to say i'm frustrated to
level
i want to just i don't even know why i'm
even writing this i'm really broken up
i really feel for bengi you know running
a business is hard
nobody tells you how hard it is nobody
tells you that they're thinking of
giving up and quitting
and the reality is bank you're not alone
every entrepreneur has thought about
giving up and quitting every
entrepreneur has thought about it we
never talk about it
you know we don't go to events and
networking events and family functions
when people ask us hey how you doing we
don't say
i don't know what i'm doing with my life
i don't know what's happening right
you talk about the good stuff but
everybody's thought about it
everybody's been in in your shoes where
you are right now and
congratulations on having the courage to
to air it in such a public forum like
youtube
i want to share my story with you
quickly and i've told it a few times
before but i think it would be helpful
here
when i had my first software company i i
turned down
high paying jobs to do this thing and it
wasn't working
and and i was frustrated and
i tried everything that i thought would
work and i was
confident you know we had a great
product it was helping people and i was
confident it was going to work and i was
you know
i felt we were smart people we had
abilities
and i was making 300 a month you know
that was not enough to survive i was i
was surviving on beans for lunch every
day and i couldn't go to my friend's
events and
you know i i lied i liked my friends uh
i was invited out to you know a birthday
party and and i'd say i was busy working
but really i i just couldn't afford to
go
you know 20 i couldn't afford that 20 to
go and have drinks with somebody
because it wasn't making anything and
you can only handle that for so long
right like month after month after month
after month after trial and failing and
trial and failing and
like how do you keep going i got to the
point where i was so
down on myself so depressed so feeling
like a failure
where my whole life i had been you know
pretty successful with whatever i tried
to do
and here i was i couldn't make this
thing happen i felt defeated and i felt
like
i lost my confidence in myself and what
i was doing
and normally i my two business partners
i got along with them very well
but you can only handle so much defeat
and failure and just
not seeing any progress
and it all came to head one day
i was at a family function i was at my
mom's house i forget what it was
and i hopped on a call with my
business partner for some reason and and
we just had different visions now for
you know well we had the same vision we
had different directions where we wanted
to take it right you know we were
fighting we
i wanted to do this you want to do
something else and
you start fighting when you're not
making money
and i told them you know what i'm done i
quit you know i don't respect myself
anymore
i can't keep doing this and not making
any money i quit i'm out i'm done
and i hung up the phone angrily and
and i just cried cried like i'm
genuinely not a huge crier but i just
cried i
bawled my eyes out i was just so like
hearing myself say that i quit and
giving up on something that i believed
in
i was so i felt defeated i felt broken i
felt broken
it was a good word and uh
my mom heard me crying and she came
upstairs and and i don't even know what
she said to me
uh she put her hand on my shoulder and
it was just so
i was so lost in my tears and my pain
and tears are balling out you know
coming out of my nose it was just
one of the worst days of my life and
that's where things that's where you get
tested
you know that's where you get tested if
you're doing the right thing or not if
you're meant to do this if this is
something you're really passionate about
or not
i remember reading famous stories of
entrepreneurs and how they started their
business and all the crap they had to go
through
i think about milton hershey who started
a business
four different times and failed four
different times in different cities and
he borrowed some money from his aunt to
get it started and when he came home
he was bankrupt nothing no money nothing
and his parents said dude you can't live
with us
you can't stay here you we disown you as
a son
and he had to stay with one of his first
employees at his place on his couch
just just to not be homeless you think
about all these
problems that people go through as
famous entrepreneurs
when they were nothing where they're
just getting started
and something kept them going you know
despite all of this crap
despite thinking about quitting and
giving up something kept them going is
because they loved what they did this is
why i harp on it guys you know
you got to love what you do it's got to
be part of you it's got to be something
that you want to keep doing
even when all this stuff happens to you
when you're not making money
because if it's not that important to
you you're gonna quit when when you get
to the point where you're broken
you will quit unless you love what
you're doing so i told my partner i quit
uh you know i didn't sleep much at all
that night
and the next day i got up and i went
back to work
because i loved what i was doing and i
was i was frustrated and broken and
wanted to quit but deep down i loved
what i was doing and i had to find a way
to make it work
and i eventually did through modeling
success
through learning what other people had
done in my industry and in the software
business
and learned their strategy and applied
it to make it work
i made it work eventually but it's only
because
i loved it if i didn't i would have quit
i would have quit way sooner
so i understand that you're broken and
for anybody watching who you know didn't
write in and you're feeling the same way
this normal guys
this is normal businesses don't just
start up when they're hugely successful
and didn't have any problems along the
way it's normal to want to quit to give
up to feel broken
and i encourage you to really look
inside and think
about what you're doing and
understand is this what you love is this
something that you want to dedicate your
life to
if it's not then then find it
and it's scary and and and heartbreaking
and hard but when you find
what is right for you when you find your
path when you find the thing that makes
you come alive you'll feel so good
i promise you you know it's reminded me
of people who
if you break up with somebody right you
break up with somebody
who you know is not right for you but
you still feel like crap
right you feel like i'm not gonna find
anybody i'm not gonna
i'm so down on myself this isn't you
know how i thought i'd live my life
and you may even do desperate things you
may
you know just date the wrong person or
go crazy on online dating or whatever it
is you just do
crazy stupid things because you're
feeling so hurt
and so much in pain but when you do find
that right person
your life changes and you become really
happy and you feel
fulfilled the same thing happens in
business when you find that right
idea even though it's it may be painful
cause you a lot of stress and
you're not making money yet if it's
right for you if in your heart you know
this is what you're meant to do then you
have to find a way to keep going
maybe you're taking jobs on the side
whatever it is you have to find a way to
keep going and if you haven't found that
yet
keep searching your heart will know when
you found the right opportunity
believe for those who watching like the
video let me know please give it a
thumbs up it means a lot to me
let me know what you think tell me about
the hard times you've had with your
business
tell me how you've gotten through please
leave a comment below they mean a lot to
me
and if you have a question for me i'll
make a video response if you leave a
comment
and you want to see more videos like
this you can click on my face subscribe
to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon